a free pool party hosted by the city of
north las vegas doubled as a site for
free covet testing and vaccines the
event took place earlier today at the
petite pool near bruce street and kerry
avenue organizers say events like this
encourage people to get tested and
vaccinated while having fun and keeping
those safety protocols
we've had a steady stream of people
coming to get vaccinated and of course
you know i i actually thank people for
thinking of themselves and their entire
families so it's been it's been a steady
stream of people getting tested and
getting fascinated
with again with with all precautions
there from the south nevada health
district
now families had a chance to enjoy free
food a live dj and games
if you still need to get your covid
vaccine a pop-up clinic will be open on
monday in the east valley this is
happening from 10 a.m to 2 p.m at the
immigrant home foundation that's inside
the rafael riviera community center near
eastern and the 95. the clinic will
offer all three vaccines no appointments
are required